un accidente cerebrovascular ocurre
cuando el flujo sanguíneo en parte de su
cerebro es bloqueado
después de algunos minutos las
hambrientas células cerebrales comienzan
a morir
usualmente el cerebro recibe sangre
mediante dos pares principales de
arterias
que se ramifican a través del tejido
cerebral
y alimentan a sus células cerebrales con
un constante flujo de oxígeno glucosa y
nutrientes necesarios para sus funciones
durante un accidente cerebrovascular
hemorrágico el sangrado anormal
interrumpe el flujo sanguíneo regular
por ejemplo en un accidente
cerebrovascular hemorrágico
un vaso sanguíneo se rompe derramando
sangre directamente en el cerebro
mientras roba el tejido provisto de
alimento
tanto la hemorragia y la falta de
suministro de sangre llamada isquemia
destruyen el tejido cerebral un
accidente cerebrovascular subaracnoideo
ocurre cuando un espacio débil en la
pared de un vaso sanguíneo llamado
aneurisma
se rompe y gotea sangre en el espacio
apretado entre su cerebro y su cráneo el
sangrado de presión alta puede dar como
resultado serios daños al tejido
cerebral
el tratamiento inmediato para su
accidente cerebrovascular ayuda a
minimizar la lesión a las células
cerebrales y la muerte
en el caso de un accidente
cerebrovascular hemorrágico la cirugía
de emergencia podría ser necesaria para
reparar las arterias dañadas o para
reducir la presión de la sangre en su
cerebro
puede que se le dé medicación para
ayudar a que el flujo sanguíneo del
cerebro se normalice